تتزايد حده المواجهات في حلب مع مغيب
الشمس اذ تستهدف مروحيات النظام السوري
المدنيين
[موسيقى]
العزل صوت المروحيات اصبح يشكل رعبا يوميا
لسكان حلب فالطائرات تحلق على مستوى قريب
من الارض ويص معرفه الهدف المقصود حتى
يسمع صوت انفجار القذائف ويبدو ان الهجمات
عشوائيه هدفها ادخال الرعب والرهبه في
نفوس المدنيين ولربما تكون المروحيه التي
رايناها سابقا قد اطلقت القذائف التي
اصابت هذا المنزل اذ يحاول سكان المنطقه
تنظيم عمليات الانقاذ بعد الانفجار هنا
رغم انهم يعلمون ان المبنى قد ينهار في اي
لحظه السكان يقولون ان الغاره الجويه كانت
قبل نحو اربع ساعات الا انهم لا يزالون
يحاولون اخراج تسعه اشخاص من تحت الانقاض
ويتخوف السكان من ان تقوم المروحيات بغاره
اخرى اثناء عمليه الانقاذ ها قد وجدوا
الجثه
الاولى لطفله قضت تحت
القصف
[موسيقى]
وبعد وقت قصير وجدوا جثه والدها
ايضا العظيم تمرنا اقسم بالله
العظيم رنا
عنا وتظهر اثار القصف واضحه في المستشفى
الذي يتم نقل الجثه اليه الس
الئ الله اكبر الله
اكر وبعد وقت ليس بالكثير تم نقل طفل وحيد
نجى من القصف الى
المستشفى الله اكبر ياشار الكلب هذا الطفل
الوحيد من
المجزره تحت الانقاض الله اكبر بس طلعونا
عليه ان شاء الله هو ما فيه شي احد
المنقذين يقول ان الطفل كان يرضع من حليب
امه وقت القصف ورغم ان امه سحقت تحت انقاض
المبنى الا ان جسمها وفر الحمايه اللازمه
لنجاه الطفل من
القذيفه ورغم ان الطفل ولد في الثوره
السوريه الدمويه الا انه قد يبقى على قيد
الحياه الى ما بعد
الثوره